and what are some good examples of
accessible products so one example I
like to share our Google Docs and drive
I feel like they've come a long way over
the past year and a half yeah and what
sorts of things do you feel like they've
done really really well well as you can
see here on the Google Docs app there's
a lot of good things that's they have
considered one is good contrast between
the text and the background colors they
allow they support large fonts really
well so that when you do enlarge the
fonts on here that essential items or
elements aren't getting cut off
either able to zoom in where you need to
and they also have really good screen
reader support and screen readers are
really interesting assistive
technologies to design for there's a lot
to consider because they not only read
the content like the words that are on
the screen but they also read and
announce the different elements around
the screen such as buttons and links and
menus and in some of the aspects of a
good experience with the screen reader
and things you need to take into
consideration are one ensuring that the
way the user kind of goes through the
page and the screen that think the
elements are in a logical order so it
kind of goes left to right top down if
that's if that's how the elements are
laid out on the screen and but another
key thing that is really important is
what we call the labels or how things
are labeled on the screen
so again getting back to this the notion
that the buttons and links and elements
like that are read to the user you want
to ensure that those have clear and
concise labels and they're very
contextual so and I think a good example
here is let's say you have a screen that
has let's say emails or search results
on there and you have pagination
controls like a next and previous button
below instead of having the screen
reader just read out next or previous
having a bit more context like next 50
emails or next 50 results is really
really about
official and a very small change from
the designers point of view right I mean
I could imagine like maybe seen a buy
button but it's like bull buy what one
thing that's really important to
understand is the way screen readers
work they go through the page very
linearly and so by the time they
traverse through the site and reach the
bot the buttons that are usually at the
bottom of the page they might have lost
some context of where they were yeah so
how can I work with a screen reader like
where would I go to use that or use it
with a product the great thing about
screen readers especially on mobile is
that they're already built in so if you
have an Android or Apple phone you can
easily go to the settings and within
there there are accessibility settings
and you can turn on talkback for Android
and and I an apple it's voice over and
my what I tell everybody is turn that on
and try to use your phone for a day and
it's get that experience doing your
daily tasks but only using a screen
reader and the key there is to not look
at your screen so closing your eyes are
dimming your screen for a day and just
see if you can achieve your everyday
tasks well that sounds pretty tough and
what's sort of other concerns are there
for maybe mobile accessibility I think
one of the unique things about mobile is
it's a touchscreen so one key thing to
keep in mind are the the touch target
sizes and ensuring that they're large
enough and this isn't just for people
with disabilities we all have different
shaped hands and levels of dexterity and
so considering that and that ensuring
that you don't need you know a small pen
tip to actually focus in on a button or
something like that
is extremely important and valuable and
what other considerations are there for
accessibility well there's definitely a
lot more but I think one other important
one that we touched on a little bit
before is color contrast and I think
it's it's a good one to focus on because
you can focus on it early just in the
design and mock stage and it's it's an
easy thing to to consider and so there
is a specific color contrast ratio that
you need to meet in order to achieve
these standards the great thing about
this is there's a ton of online color
contrast checkers that you can simply
plug in your your head
codes of your text color and your
background color and see if you meet
these these standards so it's really
easy and again just something you can
take care of and think about really
early on in the design process